excuse me
Crystal Peace by switching your heart
because
thank you so much for giving me an
opportunity to give a talk here
so I'm going to talk about the relations
between farming functions and then it'll
be hard and slow meta compressed
so uh let me remind you the different
definition of a one-way function Equity
it's said to be one way function if it's
easy to compute but how to embed on
average so it's defined to visit with
respect to the notion of average is
harmonies
multiplication
even X and Y you output x times y if you
take the inverse it corresponds to
integer Pocket Edition which is believe
it will be hard
and this is one of the most fundamental
cryptography Primitives because it is
equivalent to many crypto primitive such
as surround generator synonym oxygen
generator private key encryption digital
signatures and the commitment scheme and
so forth so it's very important to
understand whether it exists and what
the questions what is the minimal
compress the assumption that
characterize the existence One Way
function
home
um so the main question that we address
in this book is whether we can
characterize moment functions by using
some worst case hardness assumptions
and the main result of this talk is to
give an affirmative answer to this
question namely the main result is that
the following two statements are
equivalent
the first statement says that there's a
one-way function secure against
polynomial circuit and the second
statement is some worst case assumptions
memory NP is hard for polynomial circuit
if almost everywhere
and we also require that some problem
called distribution of common
compressive between products in this
work is NP Hub under randomized
polynomial reductions
remember that the notion of NP hardness
is defined
in terms of Boss case compressed so
these two assumptions are reverse case
completely
on the other hand model function is
defined with by using upright case
hardness notion and this equivalent
so that's going to be the main uh
theorem I'd like to talk to you about
today
and informally in terms of importance
firewall this means that in order to
exclude the shooting percent we need to
prove distributional chroma complexities
and be heard and this actually exactly
characterize the questions that we can
eliminate heuristic and passionate
so so this is the overview of this talk
and
um in in the rest of my talk I would
like to explain the context of this
result and in particular I would like to
review what a previous approach towards
excluding puristian patients and then I
will explain what this theorem actually
means
so let me start with very basic memory
impulsive fibroids
um I'm pretty decided that you are quite
familiar with this notion but just in
case let me review this so if it's very
influential words what what paper
Russell classified fireplace world that
are consistent with our current
knowledge so here we have algorithm type
the cryptomania and it's known that one
of them respond to our world but
currently we don't know if it's work
corresponds to our world for example
argument is a wall in PTP versus NP and
this is in this bar we can't construct a
private encryption scheme another word
correspond to a word input speeds
different from NP and this classified in
this way
for example cryptomania is about where
the publicly crypto system
and as far as a no most over most of us
believe that our world corresponds to
Crypt menu because there are several
public crypto systems that are believed
secure but the currently we don't know
whether it is true or not
and patient if it's it's redempted to
this talk is a what is called the worst
possible part in the sense that neither
we can construct a private key Crystal
system nor NP can be solved efficiently
on others
many crypto is about the inputs we can
construct private key Creator system but
we can't construct public security
system
and the heuristic is about where there
are efficient heuristics that solve NP
on average
in complexity when we say heuristics it
means that it's a efficient algorithm
that solves most instances of canopy so
in this world NP is easy on average in
the sense that we can solve most NP
instances but on the other hand it also
means that it's impossible to construct
a crypto system
so we have five possible which are
one and one of them correspond to a
world but we don't know if it's
correspond to our world the ultimate
goal of a compressed Theory and
cryptography is to decide which part of
correspond to our world in particular we
believe that some of you might
um
disagree with me but we believe that a
lot of the crystal Mania so the goal is
to this show that our already create
menu
um so what's known about this important
questions well currently we know a
previous implication in a sense for
example if you have a public security
system then we can construct a private
security system and if you have a
private particular system then NP is
hard on others I'll fix is written here
and these two enemy is not being have HP
and if NP is how do average then it's of
course and if it's hard interval's case
there's a compass reaction of this
implication corresponds to the one with
the most fundamental open questions in
compress Theory and cryptography for
example the bottom arrow means that
whether we can eliminate algorithmica
namely this question is equivalent to P
naughty correct NP
under the second replication corresponds
to whether we can get the worst case the
uppercase reduction for NP namely
assuming NDP is how the interval's case
can we show that the MP is hard on the
in on average this question is called
reservation Eliminator shooting speaker
from 543
and the third implication corresponds to
whether we can eliminate personnel and
if we can prove all the implications
then we can establish that there is a
public defender system
and the main question will direct
address in this part which way that we
can eliminate touristical patient
simultaneously so that corresponds to
this question
memory as assuming that NP is a hard
interval's case can be sure that there
is a one-way function or private degree
system
but currently there are many negative
result meaning that we need to develop
new first techniques and we for example
in order to prove P bus CMP there are
many barriers so we need to develop a
proof techniques that overcome these
barrier results
similarly in order to element the
heuristic we need to develop fruit
techniques that are not subject with
advising barriers of Black Box reduction
and the impossibility of a Harden
supplication so we need to develop proof
techniques that overcomes its barriers
and recently there is an emerging
Paradigm as you know if it is meta
compressed which makes us more
optimistic
and meta compressed to departs to the
compressive problem asking about the
compressity and there are two important
metacometation problems mscsp and the
mean 50. mscsp is a problem of computing
the such complexity over a given address
table over variant function
and mean kitty is refers to minimum time
value to promote compressive problem and
this is a problem of computing the
minimum
time-bounded minimum program that
computes a given program an even string
and by considering these questions let
me now describe approach previous
approach towards excluding heuristic
from fiber password
um a couple of years ago I was able to
prove that for mcsp or Min KD worst case
and the average compresses are
equivalent
um so remember that there are two
important Notions of compressed in
complex Theory namely was case
compressed and operated compressed
in the case of uppercase compressed D we
matter the expected running time of of
an algorithm with respect to uh input
description so that's denoted by average
VPP here in this result we consider a
uniform distribution over the Thursday
robot function and for mssp computing
the such compressive or given random
trust favor it's on average is
equivalent to the worst case compressive
approximating mcsp here Gap refers to
the fact that this problem is defined
with for
approximation of such compressed
and what's important about this result
is that this overcomes limits of Black
Box reduction and what it means is that
um
shows that if you consider any problem
that is reducible to distributional MP
by using no adaptive reduction then that
problem must be in NP Source body
industry core and please respond
so under this condition
this kind of worst case to every case
connection cannot be shown by using the
standard notion reduction namely Black
Box reduction and this is a result that
goes beyond the distance
40 under the argument is that this data
uh candidate pseudonym generators if you
are even secure against core
non-deterministic polynomial size
Society so there is a special candidate
based on problem and it's pretty to be
hardly by their support
with a quick follow-up what is special
it's only something I think there should
be many candidates
he mentioned the specific candidate is
that there's no proof systems that we
could do that so yeah yeah for some
special type of prophecies
the situation it's not lifter is it the
same
um foreign
experience
yeah yeah
[Music]
um
yeah basically it's equivalent to
Natural property so using the fact that
there are small there are a few yes
intensely using for the conversation so
assuming that Japanese is hard and
computed on average it's completely
confidence
um but and this gives our approach to us
um an element and heuristic
um let's consider this implication which
corresponds to whether we can prove NP
hardness of mscsp Japan CSP now if you
cancel that Japanese speeds and be hard
it means that assuming that NP is hard
in the last case Japan SSP is heard then
this gives uh if we can prove that also
this is a big open question
um we can combine these first steps to
average age reduction and we can
conclude that assuming any Pizza Plus
gets hard
so this gives an approach towards
element in heuristic namely if we can
prove that Gap M CSP is NPR then we can
eliminate heuristic
that's the approach that's the previous
approach about elementary
now let me talk about
um
approach towards animating patient
um so as you have heard in morning
recent in very influential result are
doing fast characterized the exist sense
of one-way function and average is
and actually there's a more classical
result uh it's very nicely done by our
importance of wrapping which
characterizes the existing to one-way
function with respect by using some
problem called T time one is the
universal problem probability
um the hardness the average height of 3
times Universal distribution with
respect to any polynomial time some
properties double distribution so the
diff the main difference is that in the
real pass result they consider a uniform
distribution but in the case of entire
reference result they consider any
polynomial time sample of distribution
and this T time one little Universal the
probability which is written denoted by
QT is somewhat similar to time bonded
compressive and it's defined to be the
probability that a random program B
prints X that's a definition of
universal probability and actually if
you know the notion called provide
chromal compressity it's a reason to
introduced if you take minus log of this
probability it's almost equivalent to
probability so you can think of this as
a Time Bond a variant of the time when
the problem
now you by using this result we can
describe a photograph approach towards
animating patients
namely if we could show that QT is NP
heard under efficient reductions then we
can eliminate the patient
actually this is the approach that Yani
described and yeah which this can be
seen by other board let me explain why
why this is the case
so NP hardness is a notion that is
defined by using vast case compressed
but if it's NP hard under efficient
reduction here we require that the
running time of the reduction is much
smaller than P where T is the time Bond
of the QT
then by using this reduction we can
induce some
instance this instance a distribution
over instances
of its 3T is distributional and be
complete distribution in the heart
so we can get some harder distribution
such that the qt's distribution and be
complete then by using your importance
result and this result says that if
there is no one with function then you
can start with QP on every sample of the
distribution so you can solve this
problem on average so that's how we get
that's how we eliminate patient
okay
so
um
so by combining this result we can
describe a previous approach towards
eliminating post heuristic on patient
this vasque establishes reduction
actually works for QT as well
so if we could prove that the
opportunity which is an approximation
problem of QT
then we can eliminate both heuristic and
patients
um but unfortunately there is a gap
small gap between
the notion of average is compressed and
this doesn't imply that um and we can we
can prove uh
um and the the MP implies
the reason is that on in one of this
result we consider error establishes
compressive which is denoted by average
p
and on the other hand in the case of
importance of living's result we
consider eruption available
so let me explain the difference between
these two motions
so uh there are two notes on the average
is compressed so we can depending on the
notion of average is compressive we can
Define variance of infinite fibroids
memory if we consider average speed we
can define a large heuristic and erase
patient
and the average P here means that it's a
it's solvable by an errorous heuristic
scheme
and this means a visual data
distribution problem is in average P if
there's a error security system such
that the error is the current version
output correct answer or if it if it
makes error it must out of the bottom
symbol
and we also require that the probability
that it pairs its utmost data
so this is errors notion in the sense
that when you make error you must output
that the algorithmics error
and this is actually this is known to be
equivalent to averages polynomial time
so you can Define by using expectation
of running time of algorithm as well
and
similarly there is a different notion
called error-prone average is compressed
or should be and we can Define electron
heuristic and error-prone patient
and the difference is that in the case
of should be
um we just consider standard notion
virtualistic stream which means that we
don't require the the lrf condition and
we just require that
um
the probability that algorithms here the
utmost data
so that's a difference
and currently so there might be gap
between
um erratic operators compressible NP and
error prone application complexity of NP
so if we could prove that and be hard on
the solve qt in about time one to do
inversary distribution then we can
eliminate errorless theoristical And
Eruption patient but there might be it
could be the case that our values
correspond to erase patient intersect
electron heuristica
namely it's a lot is personal in the
sense that NFP is hard with respect to
average P but NP is easy in the sense of
error from heuristic unfortunately
currently we tend to develop this
possibility and even if we could prove
and be hardness of meta compressed it
might be the case that we can't base the
security of one-way function on the
Vasquez compressible
so this is one uh previous one problem
in the previous approach
but actually there is another
fundamental difficulty which was
recently items divided by a very nice
work by saxena sansana
so what today's thought is that under
some prodible assumption actually the
opportunity is not NP heard and if if
you consider efficient reduction
um so remember that in the current
approach
if we could prove that Gap QD is and be
heard then we can choose the kind of
patient but we don't know whether this
is probable or not
and in particular what success is that
if the Gap is additive or Omega Ruben
then this assumption is actually not
probable
so if you consider this approach this
approach doesn't work especially for
passion rank
so that's a
another fundamental difficulty in the
previous approach
so to summarize the previous result of
the previous reversal there are several
important open questions that are
answered
so the first question is whether the
approach of using meta complexity
necessary
another question is whether there is a
meta compressive problem includes NP
hardness is sufficient for excluding
passionate
remember that in the case of a Duty it's
if we could prove that it if you could
prove that it's going to be hard then we
can admit the patient but unfortunately
it's likely to be porous
so we need to come up with other
metabolism problem
another question is whether we can close
the gap between errors and data from a
Pages completely
as the main contribution of this work is
to answer these open questions in the
portals now for the second of question
um we can instead of a Duty redirect to
propose to consider distributional
column complexity and we show that NP
hardness of distribution Chrono
complexity is sufficient for eliminating
patients
and for the first question we can show
that it's necessary in the sense that if
we can eliminate the series confession
then actually
um distribution of common complexity is
going to be hard so in that sense NP
harderness
is necessary
and for the third question
we can't still close the gap
unconditionally but if we assume that
distribution common compresses NPR then
we show that this yeah can be closed in
a certain technical sense
any questions so far
well in the proof I needed to close the
gap between errorism
birthday yeah so if we have a few
examples about function we can close it
and that's a technical approach
okay so now I would like to introduce a
notion distribution and Chrono
complexity so let me give you the notion
common question
so the formal compressity of a string X
repeated them by K of X is a x over show
this program that prints X
and an example is that if you consider
the column Festival all zero and any bit
string then the current temperature at
most programming class and the constant
because there is a small problem that
says print zero intense
and we can also Define conditional
columnar complexity overstream X even Y
and this is defined to be the shortest
ranks of our program that prints x given
input y
compressive
and naturally we can consider T time
value to promote complexity which is the
links of a shortage problem that prints
X in time t
and now let me Define t time bond with
distributional chroma complexity over
string x given distribution d
so this is the natural generalization of
the conditional column complexity
the test of a conditional
complexity we consider fixed string by
but in the case of distribution of
thermal complexity we consider
distribution over condition string
so this is
denoted by in the space
and this is defined to the shortest
program and the length of a success
program such that if we take a random
string from the distribution B then the
probability that M output x given the
given example y is at least Lambda where
Lambda is a parameter given to the
distribution
so that's a definition of a distribution
and common compressity
and in particular this generates
conditional compressive in the sense
that if you consider a Singleton
distribution of Y then this is
equivalent to conditional column of
compressed
is there any
distributions I should have in mind that
would be useful can you take that
um
yeah
for example in the case of uniform
distribution and this this is equivalent
to randomize the problem
decision the program that's interested
as the input you get the uniform around
the string and the attack test you can
think of this as a randomized program so
in that case this notion is equivalent
to randomized compression so that's one
notion
Okay so
foreign
wow
[Music]
which are called depth mdkp so this is
just a problem of approach based in
distribution going complexity and this
is a formal definition
so uh you are given a string X and you
are given distribution D which is
represented by a circuit Varian circuit
and in this way you can describe this
Vision as an input
and you are also given side of parameter
s and a success probability
diameter
and your task is to decide whether it's
yes or no case and in the yes case
um distributional compressible x given D
is at most s that's a yes and in the
notice distribution compress the it's
actually at least one perception times
this where Epsilon is any constant and
the Tau the time bond is a polynomial
but for successfully we allow some small
account
and you can easily see that this problem
is in promised MP and that's a that's a
problem we consider
and for some technical reason actually I
needed to consider our Oracle version of
this problem which I call mdkp to the A
but we are going to consider uh Oracle
in physics body so you are given an
efficient Oracle and you you want to
decide whether distribution or
compressive with respect to a Oracle is
it small or not
um
I haven't notified what is Oracle
pattern but since this is the foreign
can be described by polynomial side
circuit you can think of this as a
forward so this solution from
compressive x given d and a it's small
or not so what we show is that if this
problem is anything hard then
um we get a longer function
is related to the fact that Longway
functions are secure against non-uniform
circuits that's a very good one so the
reason why I need to have this is
particularly this
circuit it can be sort of as uh
and
if we can prove that this problem is
then because the same example function
that is secure audience to polynomial
effects
it's not an input all right
for some a foreign
[Music]
in the deduction we don't have access to
today
so we can prove the following argument
by any constant
um the first standpoint said that there
is a one-way function secure against the
precise body
and the second statement is that NLP is
hard in the last case under
one perception Factor approximation of
distribution column complexity is NP hub
and let me state it more formally so the
meaning of this NP harness
is that there is a parameters bonus
randomized no adaptive reduction from NP
to wmdkp program which I defined in the
previous slide for any polynomial type
and any polynomial inside the circuit a
so this reduction must not depend on
that any polynomial under any Oracle so
the deduction must be independent of the
Tau and a so in fact this means that the
running time of the deduction is
sufficiently smaller than Tau where
power is the Pyramid of the distribution
don't say anything about the size of the
circuit that is
yeah um as long as it's polynomial size
that's defined yes it does that's in the
part of the input to the mdkp so yeah
which is the hardest report will work
for every year
is
foreign
I guess the possible assumption would be
there's a one-way function
s
yeah
they exploit the efficiency of it so if
a is an opening is
yeah so the question is
pre-sized body condition but I'm not
sure whether that's an oracle area
doesn't work for decades
QT is just a string and you want to know
whether it's compressible or not
but in the case of distribution
X as well as a distribution so it's a
kind of conditional version and in some
sense we can encode information about
anything that's inside into the
conditional string that's the idea
so
yes
well in the proof I needed to go through
the notion before the important function
but I'm going to share about it
because I'm following is good so like
this Gap problem for any a in P such
quality this is going to be in a Visa
way of saying is that this is if you're
you want to prove that this Gap problem
is complete
yeah that's right yeah this program is
in MA to yeah ms5 and yeah yeah so with
a piece that probably work with that
whole thing is
all right
yeah actually I need to consider that
I'm a bunch of production yeah
so in some sense the reduction is going
to be a one infection right or is that
uh yeah that's right yeah that's
correctly interesting so if you consider
any reduction this translate the
government so the construction of a long
assumption comes from the reduction so
that's the idea
since it's parameterized by the
by the attacker a is it no the reduction
must be no less production is it but I'm
just saying like it's not a single
problem that we're showing every
complete problem characterizes only
functions
yeah
it's a crafting problems
sense
so instead of having the condition that
NP is having the first case uh yeah we
can consider assuming that NP is hard in
the last case memory award is not always
makeup with respect to foreign
event there is a one function security
Guardian speaker meaning that she is on
a patient do not exist and
um this relational commode this is
equivalent to visual formal compressors
can be hard outfits means that we have
nnp Hardware
so this point this characterized Rises
the approach of using meta compressor is
complete for elementary kind of patient
so I don't have time to explain those
techniques but the the current proof
technique the principle who is very
complicated but One Direction namely
every hardness of distribution from
compressive and assuming the use System
One Way function isn't so difficult and
this is similar to NP hardness of
operating password and embassies
and the compass is very complicated and
we need to combine a lot of the results
but a high level idea is isn't so
complicated basically at a higher level
we just combine a very nice result by Mr
nanasima and my vasque stability
so what narasima showed is that if NP
reduces to avoiding a heating system
which is a stronger notion than one
function
by using a black box reaction then we
can eliminate the shortest condition
that's what he showed on the other hand
in my vast guest average reduction we
showed that the poly called Prime Time
complex problem reduce it to avoiding or
hitting septu generator by using a
non-black box reduction
so the first step in this work is to
generalize this result to distributional
conformal complexity so for distribution
compressive we can also get the similar
basket reduction
and then we are going to combine these
two results but there is a gap between
Black Box reduction and non-black box
reduction
so the most of the paper is devoted to
combine these two techniques and we
assume that distributional common
complexes can be hard actually the gap
between non-blackbox and black box
reduction can be closed in a certain
formal sense and that's what is
happening in the paper
and let me mention how we can close the
gap between errors and data from avatars
compresses and this is actually uh
um identified in the back of nanasima
and the key idea is that it's to use
that Runway function is testable in the
following states
let's say you are given our access to a
where a is an oracle that price the
important function
and the condition that a in platform
function can be written in this way
and the key point is that this condition
can be tested in polynomial time so by
choosing X randomly and you can check
whether a inverse function or not and in
this sense one way function is testable
now at some point in the proof I needed
to construct error discussion and the
way I construct errorless series theme
is that we use this testability
and they found Oracle doesn't impact
one-way function then we output the
bottom single that's how I get I close
the depth between hilarious and the
electron okay
and I don't have time to explain meta
complexity
um but
um in the paper I propose some
conjecture which are called meta complex
parting quantity
which says that time bonded compressive
is reducible to distribution compressive
by using approximation preserving
parting reduction which means that the
size parameter can be increased in a
certain sense
and under this condition
we can show that we get a nicer
characterization one function by using
the hardness of
so if this condition is true then we can
show that there's one factoring randomly
feeds hard in the bus yes
and more generally
um
it is interesting to see whether
companies problem are portable or not
and after in the case of formula message
we can get the padding reduction
by using KRW conductor for parity we can
increase the formula compressible given
function by taking a composition with
parity
and it's interesting things to see
whether we can get a similar part in the
reduction for every city so yeah thank
you so much for your attention
[Applause]
there are more questions
[Music]
okay
can you prove that occasions
um
conversations
[Music]
and this is a